so we had the cyber name of the Max
Planck Institute for Biological
cybernetics and this is our tracking lab
it's a bit like the holodeck in in Star
Trek of course if you've seen the old
Star Trek episodes they suddenly go in a
room and it changes into into like a
virtual space and this is a bit our our
holodeck this is basically a large scale
tracking space this means you can walk
around in this room and if we put
markers on you we know exactly where you
are and that's down to a millimeter
level and if you know where you are we
know where your head is we know where
you're looking with your head and then
we can basically use that information to
put you in a virtual environment so what
are the seats here so you've probably
heard of HMDs like the oculus rift the
current version they're only able to
track your orientation this means you
are sitting in a chair and you can look
around but as soon as you move around or
you want to get out of the chair
you'll be still frozen to that point in
in space okay and now you basically if
you look around you should already have
the orientation tracking and what I
encourage you now to shift your head a
bit left and right because then you get
something this is what you would not get
with the traditional deaf kid one you
will get it then with the next version
of the rift but only for a very small
area and we're doing it for a big area
that's a big difference you start off in
a chair you can look around and then you
actually be able to get up and walk
around now when you want to do that you
have to solve a couple of technical
challenges and and one is of course a
very basic one which we discover every
day in our life it's cables what we've
done in the past we had quite cumbersome
setups the test subject was wearing in
head mounted display the very heavy
backpack with the video control units
and a laptop which was carried by the
research assistant and we were walking
basically behind the test subject for
one hour while they explored the virtual
environment that was a very good
solution at that time it still had some
limitations for example if you wanted to
spin around very quickly you couldn't do
it because you know someone exactly like
you have to run around around me so we
wanted to take it a step further and
really simplify things we have a very
powerful PC that's connected to a
wireless hdmi transmitter it's actually
something for the whole market and we
have here an oculus rift that's the Deaf
kid one and then we have the wireless
receiver we have a little battery in
there and you notice is it's super
lightweight it's really very comfortable
and then with this unit I can walk
around now in this room and I'm suddenly
in a virtual environment it's an optical
tracking system so they're basically
sixteen cameras which send out infrared
light this infrared light gets reflected
on these reflective markers so they're
able to really accurately determine the
position of these markers and then since
it's a fixed constellation you can spawn
a coordinate system and you really know
where you are in space it's exactly the
same technology which is used by the
movie industry to do motion capture for
video games or big Hollywood movies they
didn't have these suits on with the
markers and you probably have seen that
if you watch the making off of some of
the DVDs or blu-rays you see them when
they do this motion capture and that's
exactly the same technology but we're
using it for real-time that's a big
difference Hollywood collects a lot of
data they do a lot of nice processing we
don't have a lot of time to process the
data we need it as fast as possible in
your in front of your eyes that's a bit
the challenge then so we're not making
avatar today not today no I probably
first show you what you see low level so
if we if we go here and look at the
camera view is this bespoke software
this is a system from the UK baikin they
basically one of the standard
manufacturers for optical tracking
systems and this is basically what the
cameras are seeing they basically see
this collection of points and if you
have more than one camera who sees that
they can reconstruct and the real
accurate position in space of these
markers and that's what we're gonna see
over here then so can you pretty much go
anywhere in this room with that set you
can go anywhere in this room and then
you basically you see those markers and
then out of those markers you're able to
reconstruct the position in space and
also the orientation this is the data
which we then send to our VR system this
gives me the point of view and basically
I use that data to define my VR camera
when you play video game at home you use
a mouse and a keyboard to change your VR
camera right and he's looking somewhere
up down left right and moving and we're
actually getting the real date
from your from your head position and in
the past what we can do we can put a big
helmet on and here we try to simplify it
a bit we actually attach it to the
oculus rift so we use a bit of 3d
printing technology - we have a 3d
printer in-house so we design the model
that we can clamp that on in front of
the oculus rift and if something breaks
we can just remove it and attach it to
another plus with for example and I can
quickly show you I just grab the rift
and walk around and then you see how you
don't need any batteries you just attach
it to any object we're able to track
you're almost up to half a meter away
from the wall right now the wireless
setup we do one person because we have
interference when we have more than one
wireless signal in here if we don't use
the wireless if you just have maybe a
cable solution where you have
traditional laptop on your back we could
do like 10 16 20 people in here the
tracking system is very powerful they
use it also to track quad copters flying
objects and they've used it for tracking
up to 40 of these flying objects and
this big space also allowed us to do
research in the area of redirected
walking which means basically why do you
walk in a virtual environment we gently
rotate it and change things that we that
you think you walk through a little
village you go straight left right but
in fact you're just walking in a circle
here but you don't know it and that's
the stuff which we really that's what
our basic research is about what are the
thresholds how fast can we can we can we
fake this world rotation until you
notice it until your where's the
threshold that if below that you still
believe that you are just walking
forever through a city basically when
you walk one meter we maybe just move
you half a meter and what's really
powerful is also to manipulate rotations
so especially when you go against the
wall and you make a 90 degrees turn we
can we can we can make it fit we can
actually make you turn more than 90
degrees and you still think you just
made a 90 degrees turn and that's a bit
the tricks you use then to keep people
in this space and you can only do this
research when you have a big area tool
to examine so it's roughly 10 by 10
meters the height is then I think it's
also 8 meters also but we only I mean
for the height wires that we had the
camera set up we only track
three about four meters high the cameras
are they expensive the iron model is
basically more than 20,000 euros each
it's a bit like a Mercedes Benz it's not
cheap but it's very reliable and that's
important for us my brain is telling me
I know that there is nothing here but
visually because I can see all these
people around that I do want to try and
get out like this we run our experiments
sometimes for one hour imagine if the
system has 'm has an error after 30
minutes all the data is lost and then
you cannot rerun the same person because
they've already been exposed to the
experiment so it's fast it's very
crucial that the stuff runs reliably and
then powerful computers running behind
the scenes as well yeah
but compared to the cameras the
computers are nowadays very cheap if you
look back in the times of Silicon
Graphics these computers were expensive
they were like a million dodge marks or
dollars and now the computers are really
cheap it's a gaming market so we were
just running a gaming cart to to do the
whole thing what kind of card is that's
an Nvidia and it's not even the fastest
it's Nvidia 760 so yeah we're not
cutting edge there we don't have to
tighten black but for most of our
experiments it's efficient but it's
important for us 60 frames per second
that's the crucial part for us to do
correct VR
if you below that threshold you get sick
so at home I was playing around with
with a second life and there was an alfa
viewer that you could experience second
life in VR on the oculus rift and but i
got a really bad framerate 20 frames per
second probably and I was really then
sick for half an hour afterwards if you
are looking at the screen and it's not
60fps it's fine it's you think it's a
bit stuttering but when you have it on
your helmet in front of your eyes you
move around and it's good and suddenly
you come in this area where you have the
framerate drop it's horrible so we're
using the Unity game engine you see a
lot of mobile games done with the Unity
game engine and also a couple of bigger
titles but it's usually not the triple-a
title it's not not like Call of Duty or
so but more like the the indie
developers who make smaller but but nice
things with it and for us it's a
wonderful engine because it really
allows our scientists who very often
don't come from a computer science
background they come from psychology
that they can make an experiment in
virtue environment and they don't have
to be experts in real-time 3d computer
graphics
the second argument they've added man in
business suit levitating so you have to
go through endless thousands of stack
frame